what's up guys would frost Sahabi we
just finished listening to that clip of
Neal he's astrophysicist to distinguish
we from they he loosely clock quotes a
phrase out of the Bible by saying our
God is the God who named the stars now
this is before I was on his rolodex okay
because I could have helped him out
there the fact is of all the stars that
have names two-thirds of them have
Arabic names so this was not I don't
think his intent with that message
okay well the constellations are Greek
and Roman the names are Arabic alright
and the list just goes on and on and on
and on and so where does this come from
how does it how do how do you get us how
does this happen
how do you get stars named with Arabic
names how does this happen and it
happens because happens because there
was this particularly fertile fertile
period that Professor Weinberg duly
discussed and around that period that's
300 year period the intellectual center
of the world was Baghdad Baghdad
it was completely open to all visitors
all travelers Jews Christians doubters
which today we might call atheists they
were all there exchanging ideas oh all
of them and it was that period we had
the advances in like engineering and
biology and medicine and and and
mathematics all right our numerals are
called what Arabic numerals save it stop
and think about that you know who in
America do we pause take pause at this
why are they called Arabic numerals okay
they fully exploit the the discovery of
the zero create a whole field called
algebra itself an Arabic word algorithm
is an Arabic word all this is going on
and it's all traceable not to some long
thousand-year tradition
in the in Islam is traceable to this 300
year period this 300 year period and
then so they had naming rights the most
expensive beautifully carved astrolabes
come out of this period there's a great
collection of these at the Adler
Planetarium in Chicago if you ever want
to check them out
so navigation celestial memory all of
this is traceable to this period right
he got how many phd's too many to count
whom he made some really profound
statements of truth but then he got out
of his Lane he may have made a few
errors something happened and what
happened as was previously described I
told him that I give forgive me for
repeating from what you might have heard
12th century kicks in and then you get
the influence of this scholar al-ghazali
alright and so so out of his work you
get the philosophy that mathematics is
the work of the devil and
nothing good can come of that philosophy
that combined with other sort of
codification philosophical codification
of what Islam would was and would become
the entire intellectual foundation that
Enterprise collapse and it has not
recovered since over that period all
these books were translated into Arabic
on a scale not seen since then and so so
so why am I even going here because I'm
trying to explain to you that the you
fast forward the dangerous here is that
what you fast forward to 21st century
America and ask what influences do we
are we feeling now because that period
that naming period in Islam stopped and
it never recovered because the the the
the way of thinking about the natural
world
revelation replaced investigation okay
had Islam not collapsed in its
intellectual standing in the year 1100
and he just do the ratios rise today so
the fact that it's not only just a few
it's near zero it is deeply worried I'm
concerned about what's lost what what
what what brilliance may have expressed
itself and did not in that community
over the past thousand years fortunate
we got you got you're an expert in this
area also a philosophy and what now
so let's correct those and help him we
maybe get this message to him so maybe
he can next time he gives his
presentation he can make some
adjustments well all due respect to Neil
deGrasse Tyson even he says some things
that are very true one he said that ok
the Golden Age of Islam was the Golden
Age of science we've never had any
advancements like we've had in that
period why well in the Quran it tells
you look you want to know about God go
look at the science of God in nature it
tells you that to go out there and look
inside and look outside and study and go
and find all the answers that God all
the mysteries that God has waiting for
you so the Muslims were very Pro science
they were very Pro knowledge very Pro
logic in the Quran it says hundreds of
times reason reason is superior to blind
faith so to speak so we had a a bomb of
intellectualism a incredible boom now
all of science has a bedrock in Arabic
not all of it a lot of science has a
bedrock in Arabic philosophy now how do
we know this is what the scientific
method itself was designed by Hassan
even - people don't know this people
attributed to Francis Bacon Francis
Bacon was 300 years later his son had
been - was a Muslim scholar who
developed the the scientific method as
we have it today and of course Aristotle
had contributed very much but it wasn't
the scientific method we have today that
was the difference between deduction and
induction teaching us at the difference
between induction and deduction but Neil
deGrasse Tyson later goes on to say they
look at the Arabs the Muslims they were
at this pinnacle of science they reached
the top at the top they made the most
advance it's math biology medicine and
navigation all these these incredible
advancements the first University in
history is the in the Islamic world
anybody who was an intellectual had to
travel to the Islamic
the University of Baghdad the house of
knowledge to study what happened well
one thing he doesn't get correct exactly
is that it's the Mongols that came and
chopped down the Islamic the Islamic
world the Mongols Hulagu Khan not
Genghis Khan not Genghis Khan hulago his
net his grandson came and burnt their
libraries of the Muslims so all these
incredible books that we never had
passed down to us all this incredible
knowledge lost and for 80 years there
was a massive onslaught on Muslim people
the descriptions of the onslaught by the
Mongols onto the Muslim is horrendous
okay it's as bad as you can imagine but
within that 80 years
the Mongols also then converted to Islam
so instead of spreading from town to
town building mountains of skulls they
were spreading now we're going down to
town it's opening up mosques the Muslims
run away from Islam and then they
conquered them and then it's not good
the longer the Mongols conquered is the
Islamic Golden Age they cut down the
Islamic Golden Age and the Muslims at
that time have gone away from Islam not
necessarily they were very Muslim they
were very very Muslim they were just
they were still very religious just very
scientific mathematically oriented
logically oriented oriented towards
philosophy they wrote countless great
books those books were burned by the
mongols and then neil degrasse tyson in
the video is saying okay well how come
they never rolls back up how come the
mongols never rolled Assoc how come the
muslims never rose back up to greatness
he well he blamed that on one
particularly individual he said oh it's
because of imam hassan ii imam arrazi
ali said I'm abbreviating matters from
the devil so this is a false statement
false statement totally false like it's
one that's what number one quote that is
the central theme of his speech right
he's saying look the Muslim world has
been cut at the kneecaps as he says
because of imam arrazi Imam Hassan Ali
reformed Islam and told him the Muslims
Matis from the devil don't do math don't
think don't be logical
how can he bet how can it be wrong he's
got 12 12 PhD believe me he's wrong
because I'll tell you why he's wrong
because he's never read the works of
your mama's Ali and I say this with all
due respect because if you read even the
the if you read the works of your mom
Ana's Ali
super
surely you would know that he was a
lover of logic a lover of wisdom Allah a
lover of knowledge and science in fact
in his confessions he says that because
he has such a trust in logic he says
nobody could ever convince me that 7 is
less than 3 or the 3 is greater than 7
because that would be illogical the
definition of 3 entails that it's less
than 7 he says suppose a man were to
walk up to me and with the staff and
turn the staff into snake into a snake
and that was his proof that 3 is greater
than 7 he says I still wouldn't believe
him I'd be astonished that he could turn
a staff into a snake but I still
wouldn't believe the logical
inconsistency that 3 is greater than 7
or that 7 is less than 3 that's how much
he had of a regard for mathematics
because the other grass Tyson was trying
to it seemed like he was trying to say
point to that a Muhammad Ali believed
rather in superstition and mathematics
he thought the mathematics is from the
devil and these superstitions are from
God or it's the complete opposite Imam
al-ghazali was incredibly adamant about
this that logic and reason and science
come first and every type of illusion
you might have is ungodly or untrue that
if somebody were to turn a staff into a
snake it if they use that as proof
against logic we would have to reject
them
so superstition takes a backseat to
logic and science so I all due respect
to the neil degrasse tyson he's tried to
answer a very complex question scholars
today if you ask them why hasn't the
Islamic world risen again the answer is
very complicated and nobody can point to
one thing that's the the general
consensus nobody can point to one reason
why but in my opinion look I'm here to
tell you I think the Muslim world now
has to return back to a level to a place
where we put intellectualism and science
and the deen and we find a way to unify
them wholeheartedly and this is what he
memorizes Ali did and while all the
Muslims did at that time and that's why
they were so successful we thank him for
the truths that he was expounding on
about the contributions by all the
Muslims at that time the scholars but
you made a great
analysis of something that he said that
you corrected God woman I could get to
him next time he has that PowerPoint
presentation so he can think so happy
for ice from Tristar gym yes sir
thank you very much awesome brother just
go ahead thank you so I'm thinking it's
like when did you think that you had no
purpose are you worthless the value
comes from purpose because at the end of
the day you get something you always
want more you get some weed you want
more you get some drugs you want harder
drugs you get a girl you want a nicer
girl you get a car you want a nicer car
you get a house with a nicer house we've
got so many pressures by enslaving
yourself worshiping God loving God with
submission to the one who created you
and by worshiping going and seeking his
pleasure you get pleased